what's happening there reject nation oh
my god
the oscars totally didn't watch it saw
some people were upset by it
yeah that's my thoughts on the oscars
someone's always upset at the oscars
spending time with a loved one last
night but anywho
saw this came out and i was like
spider-man no way home villain and dark
adventure set up
yeah we are obligated to cover that we
have to all right
we need to know we need to know before
the movie gets here and that plot leak
that we cover from
cosmic wonder last time there were other
reports coming out
saying like uh yeah this plot leak is
real oh so
i oh no i know we ruined it ourselves
what have we done john
this is the price you pay for digging
for your christmas presents
sometimes you find them cool it's gonna
be fun to see how it plays out
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some spider-man 3
no way home news specifically about who
the main villain
of the film is going to be in the
about the multiverse and the spider
verse the only people who haven't really
confirmed it yet are marvel and sony but
that's only a matter of time and then a
movie that the
alpha mole that's pretty much dude a lot
of villains
so many rumored for this movie that we
were beginning to wonder if there was
actually going to be a
main villain but today it seems like we
have figured out just who this
main villain is going to be and it's
going to change the
mcu as we know it so if you love marvel
and the images
they always say and it usually
does i'm also giving away a captain
america shield that ends this friday so
be sure to check out the details in the
description down below
now in case you missed it alfred molina
did confirm that the multiverse
is indeed going to be in spider-man no
way home
he actually said that his character doc
ock is going to be from the
sam raymond university yes yes yes
and spider-man no way home with his
character is going to be
right at that moment at the end of
spider-man 2 where he is sinking down in
the water
now we all assume that he died at the
end of the movie and so did he because
when he asked director john watts
how he's going to bring his character
back when he died director john
watts said in this universe nobody
really dies
and this is very important to know for
the main
no whatever really right now is said to
be the green
goblin norman okay yeah that's what
we're saying
i'm talking about how norman osborn is
most likely going to be him villain of
spider-man no way home and just
yesterday daniel rpk said that willem
dafoe
is going to be more than a cameo okay
going back to what we said during the
plot leak though it's
really important to me as a big fan of
the rainby trilogy
it's really important to me that with
the goblin being the main villain again
this has to have an
emotional effect on tobey maguire uh
peter parker because the death of green
goblin and how that
rippled on all through the rest of the
films in that trilogy was
so integral so vital there has to be
some type
of emotional resonance or nuance maybe
that'll help enhance him as a character
more than just a nostalgic piece to be
in here yeah maybe this spider-man 3
will effectively
leave off better ends for toby maguire
spider-man than the actual one
maybe toby will tell tom holland like
you gotta get in front of him
and then when he starts to shoot his
glider you do it back
flip and it's gonna like yeah and then
it's gonna hit him in the pelvis
the upper thighs call this the spidey
pelvis the spell this
now at this point in time it's unclear
on whether or not willem dafoe's
character is simply going to
come back to the mcu switch universes
and become the main villain of our main
universe
or if there's going to be another norman
osborne in our main universe and the
other one's going to come over and
perhaps the two of them could even team
up
now again fused together you're just
like me i'm just like
spiderman do we just become best friends
nobody really dies in this universe
and one of the leaks that we've actually
heard is that the multiverse is kind of
shattering not just in our universe
but in all of the universes many
different realities are
shattering and one of the realities that
a shattering is the sam raimi universe
and what the plot said is that norman
osborne from the samurai universe is
trying to communicate with
other realities other universes he is
hoping to be able to escape
his reality that seems to be coming to
an end and go to a different reality
it says that he does make contact with a
norman osborne from
our universe our main timeline and
through communicating and a connection
type of device
norman osborne manages to make his way
from the sam raimi universe to our
universe
it said that he would then go on to
become the villain of the film
kind of trying to dominate the new
reality that he is in and also realizing
that there is another spider-man in this
universe
now it's also said that the norman
osborne from rmcu timeline
isn't that bad of a guy okay hold up
before we go into this not bad
guy norman osborne was buried yeah there
was a funeral he was
dead he died how is he doing on any of
this
even if he was trying to communicate
while he was off screen with other
universes yeah when would he have found
the opportunity to actually make the
jump
i've said this before and in case you
guys missed it it's important to me that
they maintain
the continuity of spider-man one two and
three because essentially if
toby maguire and garfield are both in
here this is a sequel to those films as
well
yes i wouldn't want them to undo it so
like oh norman osborne actually didn't
die
in the rainy trilogy because if he
doesn't die there he did doesn't that
like mess up what happens in spider-man
where did he go why didn't he come back
for revenge or was he just biting his
time did he become crazy and go away and
then try and start
he developed spider legs in a cave on
dathomir
yeah right man the cave
since the realities were kind of
shattering he was kind of just looking
to help
help his reality and help other
realities but he wasn't really counting
on the norman osborne from the same
rhema universe to be so evil
it said that he gets attacked dick wow
by the end of the
we find out that he survives and this
could have some pretty big ramifications
for the future of the mcu
if all of this comes true we could have
had a nice
good norman osborne who probably could
have helped a lot of people
but after the universe kind of breaking
and another norman osborn attacking him
perhaps his views might have changed a
little bit this could lead to several
crazy storylines or if they went a
different direction norman osborne could
go on to lead the dark avengers the dark
avengers have been rumored to be coming
to the mcu for
quite some time now and recently some
people like grace randolph have said
that some sources have confirmed that
the dark avengers are indeed coming to
the mcu
and in the comics norman osborne leads
the dark avengers
kind of taking on the role that tony
stark had after all they're kind of
similar
they're both genius billionaires however
norman osborne isn't exactly a playboy
but he does have the means to supply a
new avengers team with
that is true need and after it was
revealed in the falcon and the winter
soldier how
superheroes were kind of taken care of
as in they really weren't i mean sam
couldn't even get a loan
it would be nice to have somebody like a
norman osborne to be able to supply
everything for a new avengers team even
if it is the dark avengers team
however since it is the dark avengers
and this would be william defoe
in fact or would this be the mcu
and the winter soldier with john walker
john walker started out as
an outstanding person and soldier
however with each episode that we got
people kind of started to not like him
more and more
he started off as a pretty good guy but
as the show went on he started to make
some bad decisions
and this ultimately led him down a dark
path
now if you haven't seen it i won't spoil
it he worked a dark adventure very
similar to a norman osborne in the mcu
you see right now in the mcu we don't
really have an avengers team
but we know that there is going to have
to eventually be an avengers team
but we also know that the government is
very very
involved right now after all they were
the ones that named the new captain
america they designated john walker as
trump
in america so it would be safe to assume
that the government is going to name the
new avengers team
and this is actually what happens in the
comics with the dark avengers the
government names norman osborne as
head of the new avengers team they also
give him leadership over
shield and he reforms that agency into
hammer wow i don't think they'll go
that far in themselves no after all
shield is no longer a thing we have
sword now but director hayward is now
out of the picture
and sword does need a new director and
we don't really have any idea
on who that's going to be it could be
somebody like nick fury or
this could be the perfect way to
introduce norman osborn now norman
osborne
in the dark avengers team does take on
the mantle of iron patriot and he does
wear iron man armor
and another thing that kind of lines up
with the mcu from the comics right now
is that norman osborne was actually kind
of a hero when it came to the scroll
threat
during that time he was actually leading
the thunderbolts team
who have been rumored to be appearing in
the mcu who i definitely hope we see as
well
so norman osborne kind of goes from a
villain
to kind of a hero to somebody who's
still pretty shady because the dark
avengers aren't exactly saints and the
team members actually consist of some
villains moonstone who is portraying
miss marvel
venom actually i really like the idea
of bringing in norman osborn here and
building him
up so much to this little random
leadership position that you don't see
coming yeah i actually really appreciate
that it'd be
very different to do i mean we've been
building up thunderbolt ross and oh he
says
the thunderbolts evo we've heard all
that
for such a long time we have yet to see
any of those theories truly pay off
yet right we thought it might be a
falcon a winner soldier
oh he's supposed to be in the she-hulk
uh show okay yes he's in black widow
if they start doing that with norman
osborne if like this new spider-man
movie is the catalyst for him yeah
that'd be pretty cool i think man
especially with getting to like the dark
avengers point it would be their own
version of a
you know like suicide squad sinister six
or something yeah you know
one that's in line with remnants of
sony's old plans which were to try and
have some kind of team led by norman
osborne and supplied by ozcorp
yeah so yeah i mean it seems like kind
of an upgrade from that if they do
have them dawn like an iron patriot
outfit to toy with the captain america
symbolism as i did in falcon winter
soldier if they did the same thing
here i think it'd be bold and that
they'd be very fascinating yeah
i'd be quite into it the dark avengers
aren't exactly saints and the team
members actually consist of some
villains
moonstone who is portraying miss marvel
venom bullseye who is portraying hawkeye
and
wolverine's son dakin taking on the
wolverine mantle
so i'm imagining that if norman osborne
is indeed named the head of the new
avengers team it will go kind of like
what happened with john walker
maybe he'll want to do a really really
good job at first
but as things go on his new avengers
team may turn
a little bit dark after all norman
osborne is pretty notorious for being a
villain
i'm sure the mcu would kind of keep it
the same way and if norman osborne is
indeed coming to the mcu there are
actually some connections that we could
make that could be tied to him
sharon carter was talking to somebody on
the phone in the falcon and the winter
soldier post-credits scene
i won't mention more than that but we
don't know who she was talking to
that person could indeed be norman
osborne after all one of the specialties
just a home girl who she wanted to tell
her secret plans to who
us agent is working for now sure we know
valentina but who is she working for
there are clearly some big
organizations out there in the mcu right
now that we don't
know about and norman osborne could be
behind one of them
either way i definitely hope that
normandy that's true there are these
multiple organizations i don't really
have any doubts that that's going to
happen
of course it's not officially confirmed
but i'm sure it'll happen and then i
hope he has a pretty big future in the
mcu as he is a
major character hopefully he goes on to
lead the dark avengers team
and hopefully a lot of secrets of the
mcu start to come out relatively soon
so be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
if we find out any of those secrets i'll
be sure to let you know
in the meantime let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below do you think the green goblin
would be a good villain for spider-man
no way home and do you think norman
osborne should go on to be a key
character in the mcu
let me know down below don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
meow what is this woof woof thing that
you do
[Applause]
what's getting me excited is the
potential not of green goblin but of
norman osborne
which i think is quite a departure
because yeah it's
it's been like green goblin beforehand
but norman osborne does get
sort of get killed off in whatever movie
he shows up
so it would be neat if they actually
don't kill them off this time around and
he's someone they keep around and
especially if john watts is out there
saying your death doesn't matter yeah
that's exactly
he'll be fine well it makes me wonder
too is like if it goes down a route of
like okay the mcu
norman osborne reaches out and brings in
the norman osborne from the raimi verse
or something like that then yeah maybe
we can have it be a slingshot where it's
like oh damn
that's a really sinister version of me
that's not who i want to become and
maybe that will
at least like stay his uh
turn towards you know the dark side for
a little longer enough to at least put
him in a position to
want to rise to that mantle of you know
being the iron patriot or whatever you
know
yeah yeah yeah but i'm really hoping
it's james franco who shows up
yes you knew this was coming he wanted
a snowboard my favorite he wanted flying
snowboarding you knew this was coming
pete
hey man he made the eggs though with a
lot of gusto in that movie
yeah he did cooked the hell out of those
eggs impressive stuff
he showed up that day i know anyway guys
norman osborne are you excited leave
your thoughts down below
yeah this is what i was thinking it
would be normal it sounds like you're
building up for it to be green goblin
yeah it would make sense it's they've
sony has been wanting to do that for so
long
and their plans keep getting smashed and
i feel like now is the time
oh boy this movie better deliver all
kinds of weird experiences better have
everything in it including batman hit
that like button
see you guys soon subscribe to cosmo
wonder